[Musique]
chapeau chargé de plumes ou de fleurs
dentelle et ombrelles pour les femmes
chapeau haut de forme gants et cannes
pour les hommes
le temps d'une journée le château de
breteuil s'est retrouvé plongé à la mode
de la belle époque
une broutille en 1907 une période de
grands changements
une véritable effervescence s'empare du
château déjà il ya des travaux
considérables dans le château on apporte
tout le confort moderne
henri duchesne un célèbre paysagiste va
transformer les jardins à la française
le parc à l'anglais est en quelque sorte
l'aspect du château tel qu'on le connaît
aujourd'hui
eh bien on le doit tous ces travaux du
début du 20e siècle
une reconstitution pour rendre
l'histoire vivante
l'occasion de découvrir un patrimoine
culturel les 40 figurants échanger avec
le public pour présenter leurs tenues
parfois venus de toute l'europe et donc
là nous avons les gosses avec nous se
sont rendus chez le marquis de breteuil
donc il était habillé en conséquence
donc c'était les grands chapeaux à
plumes les blouses blanches et les
grandes les grandes jupes ces détenus
qui ont vocation à ce que les femmes
puissent marcher avec et donc ses deux
piliers une tenue d'une d'une femme de
la poule la bourgeoisie assez aisée
voilà qui part en promenade pour un
pique nique ce que nous avons fait
aujourd'hui de visiter le château de
voir toutes ces belles choses et puis de
voir ces gens là c'est des costumes
magnifiques et vraiment on est dans
l'ambiance et on oublie qu'on est en
un défilé de l'élégance pour un bond
dans l'histoire
un autre voyage est prévu le 3 juin
cette fois au carnaval de venise